everyone on the couch when you've been
toured shows the Oscars Gunners you've
all taken your parents which is that
seems you know dad four four of you all
do the same Ryan your mom she I mean I'm
sure she likes meeting celebrities but
isn't it the gift room is really her
thing she noise I don't want to help my
mom like this I will tell a funny story
about that picture though which is that
my mom was convinced that year by her
friend that beehives were all the rage
beehive you'd feel embarrassed and it
turned out to be the opposite it was a
natural hair vibe that and my mom sat in
front of Rachel wise and her hair was so
high that Rachel had to keep sinking in
a chair and I didn't know what to do
because I was you know I didn't wanted
to have a nice night so I I didn't know
Meryl Streep but she was sitting next to
me and I said in a commercial break do
you would you would you mind just
telling my mom you like her hair and she
was like I got this and then the
commercial when she goes do you know I
wish I was gonna do a beehive and I wish
I
see already know that story your mom my
mom yeah your mother does she pretend to
not know the famous people or does she
just get a bit overexcited in person we
are she well I mean that when we the
first time I went to the Golden Globes
just said let's bring that back around
that was this year we were sitting next
to now it's you know not as fun to talk
about but we were talking from sitting
next to Angelina Jolie and Brad Pitt and
she was just asking multiple questions
like if they had kids maybe what's it
like I mean I had no idea the whole time
you take your dad the year of American
sniper yeah no here's the things I think
it is a lovely thing to take your parent
to the officers but once the ceremony's
over don't you just want to ditch them
like is that you just do the publicist
kind of go and I've got no party no he
came in until five in the am really
dancing a guy series house next to John
Travolta and now he was great and
emotional and sort of just wept
throughout the whole thing yeah dance
with Prince really he just totally
taught me
[Laughter]
can we go one better you and Matt both
took your mom's mom's wish only fueled
rumors of our sexuality our moms who
look great in that in that picture my
mom my mom they do a weird thing where
like if the Oscars they put because
they'd have to rehearse where the shots
are gonna be and so on a television
business thing don't worry about it
they put big name placards of where it's
Toto say instead of J cuz it just says
Jack Nicholson you know and they'll say
like Ryan Gosling whatever and my mom
was obsessed by that and went around
taking pictures as well
there's an album mouse yes Graham Norton
here if you'd like to see even more
stuff like that then hit subscribe or
don't it's a free world but I know what
I do in that situation